all right are you looking for something
sweet this fourth of july holiday
smith's food and drug the sponsors of
the next segment show us a patriotic
treat
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's happy independence day it's one
of my favorite holidays for sure
just love everything about it especially
the food today we're going to be making
a patriotic
almost like a deviled egg but we're
going to be doing it with strawberries
we're going to be stuffing strawberries
red white and blue strawberries super
delicious super easy nothing to it you
want to get the biggest strawberries
that you can if possible and then what
we're going to do is just cut the stem
off
and then cut them in half probably
the most flat way that you can and then
out of the inside we're just going to
kind of scoop just get a spoon and just
carefully
scoop out
just to make a little well there just
like that
i'll do that with this one again
but just do it with this recipe will
probably fill i don't know probably a
dozen of these or so
wash your strawberries clean them out
and then we have to stuff them with
something white so that's the red we
need our white now
we're going to be making a cream cheese
filling and what that's going to include
is some cream cheese of course
and we have some whipped topping
you could whip your own and make it or
you can just get the
tub stuff or the canned stuff either way
this is powdered sugar
and then this is vanilla they're going
to go in there and make for our cream
cheese filling so i'm just going to get
my hand mixer and mix those up really
quickly shouldn't take too long
hopefully i don't get it everywhere and
it should be pretty fluffy not too heavy
which is what we want
give it a little bit higher spin there
okay that's ready to go so what i'm
going to do now is i'm going to put this
in a piping bag or just a zip bag and
i'm going to clip the tip of it and then
i'm going to get the rest of these
strawberries ready so i'll go to that
point okay so i'm going to hollow out
the last few of these strawberries i've
got my filling in my little zip bag or
my piping bag that i'm going to turn it
into
and then we'll get this ready to go this
is just a great light summer time
trust me you put these out and they'll
be gone within minutes
because they're delicious and they're
festive they look great
okay so i'm going to put them on
whatever
whatever serving dish i'm going to use
here
let's see here we'll get kind of
decorative here
and then
what we do next it just takes well
actually i need to cut a hole in my
little piping bag
and then we'll squirt some of this out
don't need a very big hole
okay
just put some of that right in the
middle there just like so
and then we'll that's our white so we
have a red white and then we need our
blue and i think you already know what
the blue is going to be
of course blueberries so we'll take our
blueberries put them on there
and then we have our delicious 4th of
july appetizer that everybody's gonna
love and that's super simple to make and
what i have are these cool little flags
too you can get these at smith's if you
look hard and then we'll just pop those
in there like that
and we have our beautiful
fourth of july appetizer super easy to
make thank you you can find all these
ingredients your local smiths thank you
so much for watching thank you for
shopping we will see you next time
bye-bye everybody
and thank you again to smith's food and
drug for sponsoring this segment for
more information visit smith's food and
drug dot com